in these six months we have been able to
rise to this challenge
the agreement on climate and energy the
automatic mechanisms to combat
tax evasion the declassification
that is and was and is dear to this
parliament of negotiating agreements  for
the ttp the Italian GMOs present themselves to the
fact and estimate offshore migration that
second set point to methane python
European Veneto but in short the fund to a
sense of cruz tieman flexibility
investiziuns let's be honest agreement
with the don quixote excellences campaigns
comes here and  succeeds in
elbowing respects to remove that rigor
with which the pact was implemented